go back to ethereum so when you talk
about the i brought up the nfts half the
nfts that are being bought they're being
bought through ethereum that's what i
keep hearing about the fact that people
are buying nfts through ethereum correct
but solano's all these other guys are
coming they can buy nfts through right
so is that something where if
we know nfts are not going away we know
there's going to be a fall you know the
rise in the fall just similar to the
stock market people are getting prepared
for it but if we know nft is going to be
around we know meta's not going away
it's here right that's not like a maybe
we're going to do it the moment zuck
said that everybody started googling
meta checking what that is all about
right
so
isn't that a solid argument for the
ethereum community to say
look we understand that you said what 50
per second or 15 15 15 per second
eventually we're going to figure this
out just like tesla eventually figured
it out we're going to figure it out so
my follow-up to that would be two
questions for you to answer is
if ethereum does figure it out okay i
don't know what the numbers whether they
get to five thousand ten thousand or
fifty thousand at visas level i don't
know but if they do would they be the
cream of the crop coin out there if they
do figure it out i mean that i think
that if is impossible i i would i would
put the if at
nearing zero percent but if they did if
they did
well sure i mean whoever whoever can be
the most disruptive and bring on the
most people to do the most business with
the least amount of friction should
absolutely win but i don't think
ethereum has any of those things what
about uh solana you hear that sort of
replacing the ethereum
i really don't like solana either i i
think solana solana is a really really
great implementation of a really bad
protocol it's essentially just
uh a bunch of good stuff about ethereum
and and some good stuff about bitcoin
but they've missed the boat on a lot of
things what they do have is really great
software developers so the ux and all of
this stuff is excellent but at a
protocol level it can't scale either it
hits a scale ceiling that means it needs
to be fundamentally re-engineered from
the ground up and that's not something
for example that we can do with the
internet we can't just be like all right
guys so i know we went down this path
and we're hitting a wall here we need to
shut the internet off for 90 days while
we relaunch and retool right that's
that's not going to work for the world
and that's nice i believe it was it was
shut the internet down for 15 days to
slow the spread i believe
it was yeah that worked really well too
so so i so then this leads me to a
question for you are you going to a
place where you're saying
these are the two three four five coins
that could potentially dot dot dot are
there those coins out there in my
opinion so if you look at bitcoin sv
bitcoin sv is the only
blockchain right now that has all
parameters are open and they are they
are minor settings so each node can
compete right now there is no protocol
what is the node i'm sorry so a node is
a computer that validates transactions
and writes transactions to the
blockchain so if you have a
soft wallet on on your phone and you
send let's say you're using exodus and
you send a bitcoin transaction that is
being broadcast to
nodes mining mining computers that will
write your transaction to the ledger
so those are the nodes right now in in
btc bitcoin they are not allowed to
attempt to build a block bigger than one
megabyte that's it
that's that's the swim lanes that have
been decided by software developers
whose names you don't know and who you
do not know how to position that's what
bothers me a little bit about bitcoin
the the anonymity look i understand why
people who made billions and billions of
dollars would not want anybody to know
that they had billions of billions of
dollars sure but you find out there's
some you know like finding out people
like calvin air and you know some people
that are really really
let me just get right to it i mean like
satoshi does he exist does he not exist
does
is it a real person is it amalgamation
and if you can't know who's controlling
this why should you invest anything in
it well and that's the thing i mean it's
a zeitgeist right it's it's the exact
same thing with
this is the word of the day that's a
word of his life
pots and pans so you can tell gerard
prepared that question for that so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you